my next guest is seeing the flow of
migrants first
hand he calls the situation a slap in
the face and he's pleading with
washington for help
bruno lozano is the democratic mayor of
del rio texas
and he joins me now mayor welcome
describe to us what you are now seeing
on a daily basis uh
you're situated right there on the
border good afternoon thank you for
having me so for
over the last seven days and now the
number of average detainees is now 700
individuals and
that are detained this morning i did
speak with chief squirrel of the border
patrol sector for del rio and he advised
me that this morning there was
just under a thousand individuals
detained and of those about 256 of them
were
unaccompanied children so it's
definitely getting backlogged in the del
rio sector for sure
i know that uh texas of course had uh
those historically devastating
storms those winter storms and and
because of that you actually made a
video you had the foresight to make a
video
you sent it to the white house and
apparently you said we don't have the
resources for
what you anticipated would happen what
was the response from the white house
well i did speak with julie rodriguez of
the white house
and um they they stated that they were
trying to facilitate the needs and
trying to come up with a plan of action
but
this is nothing new we were managing it
in 2019 and here here we are in 2021
managing another immigration crisis
of a great proportion and nothing's been
done you know
and it is about and border crisis in my
in my opinion because there's no plan of
action and seeing what we're seeing now
with what's happening in
the rio grande valley with with people
wrapped around in in blankets made out
of silver i mean it's just it's just
kind of absurd
what's happening why why do you say
the way the administration has handled
this you personally feel it's a slap in
the face
well because when you're pleading with
with the president to to stop the
release of migrants into your community
while we're dealing with a weather
phenomenon that hasn't happened in 20 to
30 years
and we only get three or four days of
that time you know per the border
control sector which by the way we have
a great relationship
down on the ground with our with our
chief with our chief and and
non-government
organizations it's just really like you
know whose side are you on the american
people were without
water electricity for days on end in del
rio texas and you're going to release
migrants
you know those individuals that are
seeking a better life and opportunity
into this into this weather phenomenon i
just understand how that's
i don't even understand how that could
even happen
now there are obviously other issues as
well uh according to
the border patrol's website u.s border
patrol criminal
alien encounters for this fiscal year at
4140 uh
la all of fiscal 2020 was just twenty
four hundred
that's an enormous surge how does a
small town like yours handle something
like that
well i can tell that the people that
don't really are beginning to get really
nervous and scared
i know that today i had a small a small
business owner she does photography for
the community and
she was giving me first-hand experience
of migrants asking her for food and
shelter and she was worried they were
going to steal her equipment because
we don't know how destitute and
desperate these individuals are there's
a humanist
humanitarian side of things that that's
being left out you know you had the one
side where
the border patrol is being scapegoated
for inhumane care
yet on the other side you have a mother
a guatemalan mother just yesterday who
swam across the rio grande with her
nine-year-old
daughter and three-month-old son the
border patrol responded to that trying
to rescue and revive the mother and son
which they succeeded but unfortunately
were unable to revive the
the daughter so which is more inhumane
the mother crossing with her two
children or the border patrol trying to
revive
them that's a question for for for the
administration
you know yeah you know well you know i
hear the administration i've heard nancy
pelosi use the word humanitarian several
times
uh and yet uh the images that have
leaked out
are just devastating heartbreaking we've
got some on the screen now but
people are wondering what we're not
seeing we're what we're not seeing since
there's been a press blackout of all of
this
what would you like to see the white
house do from here mayor
because it feels again we're getting
conflicting reports on what they're
doing what they're trying to achieve
what would you like to see i'd like for
them to first of all recognize that this
is a humanitarian crisis you know this
this behavior is unlawful behavior no
matter how you want to call it if the
if the people are trying to cross give
them a better life you know entering the
united states
they're being set up unsuccessfully for
one thing because they're going to be
going into our communities hidden behind
behind closed doors you know being paid
under the table what have you or sex
slavery
you know and then another side of things
you know you're condoning the organized
criminal activity in mexico
because that how do you think these
individuals are able to traverse mexico
not through google maps or apple maps i
can tell you that much they're they're
they're speaking and talking to
organized criminals that that get them
here
and that's condoning that unlawful
behavior on both sides of the border
we need to mayor uh we wish you luck
yeah we do need a plan for sure
and and the country is recognizing that
of course you see it firsthand
and that's why we appreciate your time
thank you very much thank you for having
me
president